No matter how serious, every movie is made
with the assumption that fans will be looking
at the exact characters, objects, or action
that the director intends. But sometimes,
people wind up watching anything but. Whether
it's overzealous extras, subtle jokes, or
mistakes from the crew, sometimes watching
the background of a movie scene can be twice
as much fun. If you like this video make sure
you stick around until the end for links to
more videos like this one! Here are Screen
Rant's 10 Hilarious Details Hidden In Popular
Films.
The Godfather
In a perfect world, movie audiences would
never even notice a background actor, since
they should be invisible - if they're doing
their job. The Godfather is hailed as one
of cinema's greatest films, but even IT falls
victim to one hilarious blown take, thanks
to an extra who steps into frame well ahead
of her mark. Once you see her pop into view
and quickly sneak back out, you'll notice
it every time.
Gladiator
Director Ridley Scott had to rely on computers
to recreate Rome's massive Colosseum, and
the thousands of spectators sitting inside
it. But background extras were also needed
for closer scenes, which opened the door to
some less-than-historic cameos. Like the audience
member creeping over his fellow Romans to
make sure he gets into the entire frame of
the camera that really isn't supposed to be
there.
The Hobbit: Battle of The Five Armies
Peter Jackson's trilogy may star a Hobbit
and a squad of Dwarves, but it's the Elves
who show up to help save the day, with thousands
and thousands of soldiers, too. The Hobbit
Trilogy took some flack for using too much
CG, but that wasn't a problem for this scene:
every single one of the elves is given the
exact same face, copied and pasted over and
over again. Unless elves mastered cloning,
it's one massive detail the effects team overlooked.
Speed
Getting a city bus up to 50 miles per hour
isn't easy in any situation, but threatening
to blow it up did the job for Speed. The action
takes place on freeways, city streets, and
even an airport, with the constant threat
of an explosion keeping viewers' eyes stuck
on the bus. It's a good thing, too - otherwise
they might notice the cameraman filming the
action, not eventryingto stay hidden from
prying eyes.
The Hunger Games
In the world of Panem, nothing is as important
or terrifying as The Hunger Games. With each
and every boy and girl of age eligible to
be drafted into a battle to the death, the
selection ceremony is tense to say the least.
But not for everyone, since one little girl
in the crowd is apparently more interested
in her fingernails than her life being on
the line. Kids…
You Only Live Twice
The only thing as famous as this James Bond
movie's villain is his signature white cat.
But even if Blofeld managed to keep his cool
while his base was overrun, the cat was a
different story. Apparently nobody thought
about what would happen once an explosion
was set off next to the animal, which means
audiences can watch as the cat loses its mind
in real time, forcing actor Donald Pleasence
to keep it in a death grip just to get through
the scene.
Death Proof
Quentin Tarantino doesn't usually try to hide
the movies and characters that influence him,
and Death Proof is no exception. When the
leading ladies are enjoying drinks and dancing
before Kurt Russell's villain enters the picture,
he's already been introduced... sort of. It's
no surprise to learn that Russell's role as
Jack Burton in Big Trouble in Little China
is one of Tarantino's favorites - a fact made
clear by the hero's tanktop hanging from the
bar's wall.
Star Wars: Attack of The Clones
The first Star Wars prequel may get some of
the harshest criticism of the series, but
the tie-in video game has a lot more fans.
Star Wars: Episode 1 Racer put players behind
the controls of their very own pod racer,
and they weren't alone. When Anakin and Obi-Wan
head into a nightclub in Attack of the Clones,
actual footage of the game is shown - apparently,
it's just as much of a spectator sport as
droid football.
The LEGO Movie
Most of the inside jokes and references in
The LEGO Movie make sense once viewers realize
they're watching a young boy playing with
his father's carefully-constructed LEGO sets.
But one joke managed to slip by plenty of
fans. When the heroes first take a trip to
Cloud Cuckoo Land, the random blend of toys,
themes, and characters makes absolutely no
sense whatsoever. It's never spelled out,
but when the boy's father is revealed later
in the movie, he points out the LEGO and toys
his son IS allowed to play with - a box of
mismatched toys in a cardboard box, complete
with a "Cloud Movers" logo.
Kingsman: The Secret Service
There was one sequence in this spy thriller
that no fan could ever forget, pitting star
Colin Firth up against a church full of rampaging
maniacs. The actor trained for months to be
able to pull off most of his own stunts, and
the frantic ballet of over the top violence
is almost flawless. Until you notice the one
background actor who is less than bloodthirsty,
swinging a chair so gently he's barely breaking
a sweat.
Those are the jokes, easter eggs, and mistakes
in movie backgrounds that caught our attention,
but which ones did we miss? Let us know in
the comments, and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more videos like this one!
Make sure you click on the top right link
for more hilarious details in movies! Thanks!